[Music]
to some he's a villain if his team is in
succeeding it's anyone but his fault
to others he's an inspiration just do it
but there's no denying that he's
instigated a lot of kicks Turner Envy
has kicked both SVG and I it wasn't a
very peaceful exit fallen on hard times
my concentration is very bad I'm on a
downward spiral and become something of
a pariah I think it's about time that a
lot of you at home stop rooting for the
villain but here's the thing he didn't
start out like that this is gonna be
damn close so much on the line here
internal injury might be able to do it
to get his teammate place lgt they just
want the throw but they can't
it's ND oh my god because he died
let me with the theory Jade's the crane
hits again this is the story of how I
sama one of DotA's most adored heroes
lost his way
the story of eternal enemy mine is a
dude who really really [ __ ] about so
in Jacky eternalenvy Mouse entrance into
eSports was more infamous and iconic
than most let's take you back to 2011
Jackie now 20 years old
is a self-described shut-in living in
the strict Chinese Canadian household in
which he was raised an engineering
student at the University of Toronto he
spends his days slaving over math
science and everything in between when I
actually gone to inside which is you
know conserved the harness of course in
all of Canada and I was extremely
competitive but it's not who he aspired
to be a proud otaku envy was inspired by
the unlikely heroes of the anime he
adored and dreamed of turning dota into
his life but first he had to tell his
parents I knew that I would have to do
it no matter what so I just went down
staring at him like like I apologize
that I was like like I'm just so fahnny
to do that's all monkey boy y'all see it
today see yeah yeah oh yeah I know is he
the person he aspired to be was Jaedong
one of Korea's greatest professional
gamers who Starcraft career had taken
its own enemy like trajectory but Jaden
was half a world away
living in a time and place where eSports
was already well established envy wasn't
there was a bunch of interviews about
her and a bunch of people talking about
him they always say how he tries so hard
he would only understand why he tries or
how he does in when they asked to meet
his layoffs I don't really know I just
there's a lot of fire in his eyes and a
lot of firing what he does in general
and I really respected the way that but
Envy wasn't deterred Valve's first-ever
international had taken place less than
six months earlier and envy was
confident that he had what it took to
play on that kind of stage even though
he'd never actually played dota 2 he
just one day came up to me and told me
I'm gonna drop out of school and go pro
in DotA
if I fail and I try my best then it's
fine that's a seat then it's great so I
have to do it so he decided to publish a
now-famous post on the Team Liquid
forums that informed the community of
his decision to take a break from school
and pursue the eSports dream and he got
roasted for it silly stupid or downright
psychotic that's what they called him
but it didn't matter
envy didn't care what other people
thought he was determined to make it at
all costs can't exactly have a voice
about you know dropping off school for
dota I don't think a lot of people
should do that or almost anyone should
really do that when my friends found out
that he was gonna do this and he saw the
whole entire throwing team liquid they
were pretty much saying that I like his
kids a joke you know like he's not gonna
make it come April 2012 NV had committed
to playing dota 2 full time he knew he
had the talent but still needed a team
and come September he got 1nv joined no
tidehunter after a few changes to the
initial roster no tidehunter quickly
established themselves as one of the
strongest rosters in the west their most
notable performance was at Dreamhack
winter 2012 were under Envy's leadership
they not only took first place but
orchestrated one of the most famous
plays in the game's history the level 1
roshan bait and here we go
haha game is on day is lame there's a
small blood patch were Admiral bullet
wrap and it is trapped because they came
to check for it
then the Sun Vicarage I don't know
they're gonna bring it down oh boy James
now will the beat is the Swedes may pull
something out of the bag ten feet is
gonna go down as well
Oh tidehunter water stop what a strategy
coming out for material Envy no one has
ever done that no one has ever done that
in the history of dota now before we go
any further it's important to understand
that there are two things for which
eternalenvy is notorious the first is
his outlandish play he's a risk taker
one who's constantly striving to
innovate the game in ways which are
interesting unexpected and well
downright insane out there Oh eternal
Envy what a frickin player often it'll
pay off and whatever crazy thing and
he's cooked up something which almost
certainly shouldn't work does LGD
they've got the numbers advantage they
get a tier 4 Tower now as well Envy from
the enemy shop he'll go into the tier 4
as well it's gonna be really close to a
winter scene I trying to defend his best
they can't Bob that he's bought bags
he's doing what damage he can radiant
they still have to collect that
something he dead in his tracks but they
can't focus and thrown themselves
instead they have to deal with the
heroes fought to do a lot of damage this
is gonna be damn close so much on the
line here from internal and we might be
able to do it to get his teammate place
LGD they just want the throw but they
can't its nd oh my god the problem is
that sometimes things don't go as
planned and everyone is left wondering
what the hell Andy was thinking in the
first place Oh God Roshan a hunter HP
and garters gonna walk in a gift from
heaven bestowed upon him again gentleman
and he popped back the most eternal
anything he bought may be bought back to
try and get overtime the community
devised a term for this and even went so
far as to give it its own subreddit that
pays homage to envies remarkable ability
to ride the line between genius
and stupidity can be pretty low can they
do this centuries down they'll go in
straight away with a snowball and beasts
gonna get caught out by the first stun
it does half the time that's available
if he needs it in fact he's just turning
for that punching into a spawn now he'll
go for the laps looks towards s4s Paul
gets the Sun it's night and be
incredibly low running himself back
through the treeline
oh gee they're hunting they've got the
switch in the pawn ms4 group of the face
you've test portfolio incredibly loners
Paul's gonna fall they're gonna get the
kill Gerak's now trying to get out of
there but he may fall as well he does
it's a double kill for envy now Luther
was five light rum the TB my universe is
there with the burrowstrike fanatic
cleanup the other thing for which he's
known is his abrasive personality when
you first meet Jackie mouth as a person
you might think of him as someone that's
maybe a bit more rude you want me to
understand why but if you really get to
know him it's just because he's trying
to be completely honest with you but
what he lacks in social decorum he makes
up for in candor particular pink co
single item : 1000 Carosa Oh take good
I'm sick today work on the welcome to
want so yells very tell that to you man
even today Envy is both hated and loved
for his brutal apathetic approach to the
game he's always understood that when it
comes to playing dota friendship and
loyalty aren't necessarily pathways to
victory it's a lesson he learned the
hard way
despite leading them to two premier
tournament wins no tidehunter made the
decision to kick Envy in favor of
Swedish support egm it wasn't personal
they claimed just a way to take an all
Swedish roster to the International 2013
did the Swedish idea like is true sort
of but it's not the comes out the reason
to like a kick like on that team I was
only truly friends of s4 and you know
they were just fighting for her friend
at beach young whereas I wasn't really
their friend so the kick was completely
fine III never ever said that kick was
was bad and II was forced to sit idly by
and watch as his former teammates won
what was then the biggest tournament in
eSports history
[Music]
down but not out
envy decided to start from the ground up
he switched to playing carry and in
March 2013 joint forces with Ali 2000 on
a revamped type II roster that would
later rebrand as speed gaming he was a
very special cleric as he has home
he's probably smartest player in DotA in
terms of like mash and like like
thinking about things in a more like a
mathematical way I guess like he can
tell what like he likes to simplify the
game into like equations and like he
likes to play the same style all the
time and it was with speed that NV would
secure the most hilarious and miraculous
tournament win of his career MLG
Columbus 2013 how are you mixed feelings
right now mixed feelings why well like
I'm strangely confident and excited for
his tour ends ok which is very strange
because my team is [ __ ] okay
straight up with the help of one of
Envy's closest friends arteezy and the
bafflingly effective strap that was
blink clinks speed made a miracle run to
the grand finals and we're looking to
pull off one of the most triumphant
upsets of all time against team DK then
they go burning comes in no call down to
boy just yet he's holding a reserve the
audio comes from the backside it's our
T's he cleaning up he breaks out to he
might bring down everybody by himself
three heroes dead burning on the run
he's gonna die here Watson if he dies
once it's probably twice maybe not
familiars pursue out art easy gem it's
the dick
äúi snakes now burning with no BKB
nowhere to run Noah died it's a team
wine in the basis of turtle Envy in the
face is really busy forget about that
he's going bottom he's working on the
tier 3 cliffs gets forced out more
buybacks buddy TPS away what a magician
please e sama have mercy they pop the
Shiva's they force that then they drop
the off
a job rapier hits the deck nobody picks
it up they don't even need the rapier
they say we'll kill you anyway
dowsing seems negative he's gotten the
big bad sword friends of Linda speed
gaming IO champions here at MLG Columbus
speed had proven that they were the real
deal and after a falling-out with their
manager the roster announced that they'd
be representing a new more prestigious
org cloud 9 NV ally
bone7 pile I'd I sing sing and later
FATA this roster will live on an infamy
for their creativity explosivity and for
a time loyalty see Envy had this
philosophy by which he abided to avoid
playing with superstars and only ever
win alongside his friends over the
course of their 18-month lifespan cloud
9 earned a staggering 10 second-place
finishes
no matter how well they did c9 simply
couldn't close much of this has to do
with Envy's uncanny ability to
orchestrate incomprehensible throws
right click down load and now moves on
to another one's boat 7 he goes down
he's gonna throw a cloud nine
but now both sevens can be on the place
and tourists after with the extra bit of
disabled they're still going for throne
in heaven but Eliza just wiped out the
rest of time max resistance Alliance
they get the big damage to our cloud
do it all the way
to overthink everything and overlook the
most basic little details gonna back off
they don't even going for the rats right
now
where are the teepees vods it does not
have a teepee and B also I don't think
as a teepee
no one has CP there's no millions came
to say oh no it's a catastrophe the
cloud nine he comes as far as well they
just running back there running for dear
life they couldn't protect the base
chasing that pups the ultimate there's
no cover bail he dies in the mountain
when he's got ages he can't even fight
back and TP or they just get thrown over
this holy [ __ ] I can't believe it what
just happened
to rely on the ridiculous at a time when
the obvious would have sufficed envy
shifting over he wants to buy something
to help him go for oh he sees some gems
there's a cheese tower but that's who
envy is I don't even know how to
describe MBC so just a unique individual
like I think it's like it's like it's
like Sanna me just does whatever I guess
a player whose greatest opponent is
himself does matter let's fight them
let's let's go fight them the other
matters far to go just go oh my god
I'm so good at dota and bad at the same
time is amazing and man was he a trihard
froggy without fur okay
for on KTP top fur on KF TP top fur on
Katy B top furry on ket P top ok tippy
top corner we know we does the track oh
no we need that oh we need to echo slam
on the gyrocopter right now right now
right now right now right now go under
the cheese of the cheese's of cheese the
aegis and she's agents and cheese
without room we do not room we do not
have room within our room your stick
your stick your stick drop your stick
drop your stick one who inspired a lot
of memes you think it back to back to
back if you like a tip you know if
you're at a tip you know if you like a
tip you know but right now right now
like he's the best it wasn't long before
ee sama as his followers endearingly
referred to him started to develop
something of a cult following in
addition to being DotA's clowny a
superstar he managed to build captain
and carry cloud 9 during a time when
china and europe dominated the world
stage but one thing continuously eluded
him come ti4 he hoped to change that
after defeating three-time grand
finalist na v c9 were tasked with taking
down vici gaming and even though Envy's
unorthodox drafting urn c9 a win in the
second game
with a bow come the third his decision
to do a level one Roshan cost them the
series following their top six showing
at ti4 c9 still weren't able to shake
their second place curse it was then as
2014 drew to a close that Envy
instigated a fateful kick of his own out
went ouch and pile I'd died in came
misery and no tail we didn't really know
to do to make us you know become a
championship team you know people like
we're playing like watching a siesta go
stream during the final it was obvious
that the team didn't really have faith
and the community wasn't happy about it
and neither was Aoi
I don't think I should have been kicked
from that team still I think but I think
I changed Nia to happen I thought that
the changes it's gonna be how we work on
it in Envy's mind the hope was that
going into TI v c9 would finally be able
to achieve the first-place finish they
so desperately craved but it didn't work
out that way despite getting off to a
characteristically creative star or
anything but bone7 is gonna try to snipe
the courier it's not in range though is
there the next level strats all vibe
seven suicide admit me felon who spent
in his gold it soon became clear that c9
weren't what they used to be full
eternal life he goes down both seven now
Bob subway Bell but it's too late
and now fauna Oh everything's just
falling apart for cloud nine
Phaedra gets threatened by the ultimate
from eternal Eppie how it does pick up
the double kill towards the end there
and it seems like vici gaming are all
gonna be effective cloud nine college AG
that in kicking alley a player who would
go on to hoist the ages of Champions c9
had lost a part of what made them so
special in the first place following
their humiliating finish at ti5 cloud
nine disbanded fed up with where his
so-called anime way had gotten him envy
journey to Europe and join team secret
where he would play under one of the
greatest captains ever to touch the game
and it was during the secret era that
Envy finally hit his stride in fact it
was in Game one of secret series against
evil geniuses at valves first-ever major
in Frankfort where NV put on what is
indisputably the greatest performance of
his career it is referred to simply as
Envy's double rapier ember needless to
say he sama did not show mercy but
that's the one way the cella grave will
not keep this rapier safe on team secret
left me with the Siri Jade's the crit
hits again this nor return damage coming
in from secret town ten love you will
arrive now
happy it's over on on TV can they kill
him off in time the skewer off the tile
enemies looking for the clean damage but
they both through the Agassi model the
pie light died getting down to ten lamby
you'll come back to living but for how
long but find a bit CG perfectly split
so they don't get that spill damage
people in service now the BKB chart
showing the damage on fear very much he
is beyond godlike penitent lamby will
help the bring down universe turn and
there it is good Damon but things didn't
go the way they would have had this been
an anime RG they are the champions envy
wouldn't let the crushing loss deter him
and once the next major in Shanghai
rolled around it was clear that secret
meant business after toppling og in the
first round
secret found themselves in a rematch
with eg and despite envy orchestrating
some truly three to two great throws I
think he's gone
[Applause]
Oh secret prevailed they want to see
this kill happen they want to see
atterlin be go for the one versus three
play and he will go for it Kuro
immediately the target the shock wave
goes off first
they're heroes but now puppy's gonna be
able to join them he gets the deuce on
him a tough amana snowballs say for the
moment b-but it's Colonel F he's already
cleaned up - still not enough another
shackleshot we ha he showed it big in
the poker went down in their face but
now we I was going to be able to make
sure it's a total wipe and there it is
congratulations team secret take game
for finally after years of anguish Envy
was able to come out on top
to call himself a major winner but a
major winner isn't the same thing as a
TI winner secret were on top and wanted
to do everything they could to guarantee
a TI win so in preparation for the
Manila major they kicked misery and we
ha and brought in our TZ and universe on
paper secret looked unstoppable but it
quickly became clear that they were
anything but
the puppy he'll go down as well this
reported a secret notify backs available
been secret getting entirely outplayed
this game by Empire don't lie don't have
any the secret hey raging right before
GG after bombing out of Manila universe
returned to eg and secret were forced to
pick up Bulba come TI the feeling was
that in breaking his self-imposed no
super star policy and ripping apart a
major winning line up along the way NV
had flown too close to the Sun following
secrets humiliating turn out at CI six
NV wanted to give the friendship model
another go he called up an old friend
and in an effort to return to his roots
founded his own roster team and P it was
also around this time that NV released a
blog post in which he accused secret of
mismanaging prize winnings and
sponsorship earnings the claims were
quickly corroborated and NV was
applauded for having stood up to secret
especially since the organization
restructured as a result unfortunately
NP weren't able to hit a stride and even
though they'd promised that they'd never
make roster changes and V knew that
another kick was in order the team had
already stopped believing in itself he
said and he felt the need to act Post
DAC eternalenvy has checked both SVG and
I from the team not really gonna go into
much details about it in this video but
what I will say is it wasn't a very
peaceful exit for either SVG or me but
as always the hope for env was that the
bad publicity would be worth it
the price for SVG in 1437 s departure
was the return of Fatih and pile I die
with bone 7 as their coach and cloud 9
signing them for ire to TI 7 NP had
quite literally become c 9 2.0 how about
how Envy came together which is I know
now now cloud 9 what was the spirit with
which
and we kind of started building that
team and bringing you on board because
it felt it did feel a little bit
different from the beginning how sorry
was this we wanted five people who are
willing to learn together and try to
like grow as a team unfortunately things
didn't go the way they'd hoped and Gigi
despite all their talk of friendship
loyalty and longevity
cloud9 disbanded immediately after TI
seven having burnt many of his western
bridges and he accepted an offer to play
with fnatic in Southeast Asia no test on
season was probably like the worst
season ever had for dota and then after
that season I didn't really have that
many options and na / Europe had a feel
but like I wasn't even like the first
option as usual envies new lineup did
fine but not great and as usual after
several months of winning qualifiers and
barely making it into top 8 NV saw it
fit to make a change
out went Ohio a player who'd been with
fnatic for nearly three years in came
universe of all the kicks Envy's ever
been accused of instigating this one was
the messiest roster lock news drops you
tell universe to fly over immediately he
flies over you didn't feel that he was
in the condition to play in the
tournament immediately because he just
flew and we're like I was like a feeling
we just assumed it was a pro-gaming
assumption so then and then we had to
play it you felt you had to play the
qualifier with Ohio you decided not to
tell him because you felt it would
impact his performance and so on you
know unfair to your team and then and
then you guys win and then you were you
want to do the kick him immediately or
tell immediately and then you regret not
being there for the actual kicking after
the beat spark it's not exactly clear
what happened but one thing is for sure
the community was quick to lay the blame
on Envy given the TI 8 was being held on
Envy's home turf it felt as if the
tournament could be his chance to make a
comeback despite clawing tooth and nail
fnatic finished groups just barely out
of the upper bracket which meant that
for the third year in a row NV would
have to play a best of 1 in the first
round of the lower bracket
jumping from pyw he jumps in to go to
play there goes the der Linde there
comes my back every first time touched
on the penis with no buyback either he's
dead for two minutes an arrow comes out
another swing and a Miss they're from
fnatic cuz he just seemed to have no
lock despite all of the ridicule
all of the vilifications people felt he
deserved it was a heartbreaking sight to
behold I want to try and understand you
know what's running through your mind on
that stage and while you stand here now
this is too short I feel - I mean I feel
like loss thoughts are inappropriate as
well like I mean I'm sure people can
understand how I feel and like I don't
think they could be able to explain as
well it's just there's a lot of emotions
a lot of different factors that kind of
play and it's not just like the factors
I've drank yeah but like throughout the
year or the year coming out of TI 8 it
seemed as if Envy's name didn't carry
the same pedigree at once did all he'd
ever wanted was to win and after years
of doing whatever it took of repeating
the same mistake over and over again it
felt as if he'd gotten kind of lost it
wasn't long before he was offered a spot
on complexity but after several months
of subpar results
he left of his own volition from there
NV started bouncing from roster to
roster always in preparation of a
different qualifier always to no avail
in December 2018 he started flying
penguins where he didn't list the help
of an up-and-coming mid laner named
Gunnar only to kick him the moment
another more recognizable player was
able to replace him by March 2019 flying
penguins had disbanded and in an ironic
turn of events NV joined the very team
that Gunnar joined after env2 kicked him
team team it was with this roster that
NV would qualify for the first premier
tournament he'd played since TI 8 the
MDL disneyland paris major with the
major on the horizon a poor result at
ESL one mumbai resulted in NV kicking
Gunnar
again we kind of got like threatened to
get kicked before this event and they
told us we played this event in the
minor or the major and then they kind of
backed out on that like last minute
because we didn't do amazing at this
event so I think it's kind of personal
between us I think Envy doesn't like me
I don't know what everyone else that's
how I feel at least on the team that's -
the last team as far as the community
was concerned this was the last straw
if his team isn't succeeding it's anyone
but his fault and part of this is
probably like a bit of personal
frustration because he I was at a point
told like face to face by Jackie Mao
himself that we were very we were the
same person but I knew how to talk to
people which is [ __ ] I care about
other people and I've read a lot of
fictional books - not as much anime but
the hero of a story they demonstrate
qualities like loyalty and honor and
faith and their friends and I think it's
about time that a lot of you at home
stop rooting for the villain
[Music]
envy is one of those few competitors who
you either look up to or absolutely
can't stand but he isn't a villain he
isn't evil malicious or trying to
sabotage the lives of his fellow
competitors he isn't snaky dishonest or
guilty of the kind of organizational
belligerence he's made a point of
exposing he's simply a desperate
competitor who's spent years trying to
win the way others did before him Envy
isn't a villain he's a hero who's lost
his way
plenty fingers like no matter how much
you close on you I don't feel a chilly a
whatever understand him
say what you will about Envy he has the
courage to be himself in an environment
where people are ridiculed scrutinized
and abused at every turn to some that
makes him an annoyance to others it
makes him an inspiration and for a great
many number of people
that's what Envy is was and always will
be someone who chose to believe in
himself at a time when no one else would
people relate to me because I'm sure a
lot of people concern like not exactly
dropping out of school to pursue their
goals but doing something else that's
not the social norm or not what your
parents expect of you not what your
friends expect to be a boy you expect
yourself and fighting for that of
everything about who dared to think
outside the box no matter how silly it
made him look at that point you don't go
forward a beautiful loss you just go for
suicide oh yeah you have to make this
game way more chaotic business and make
it into a game where no wonder stands
out anymore because if both teams
understand daughter right now that both
teams understand them eg I've lost the
game someone who wasn't afraid to do
things on his own terms
Sammael was talking about how Colonel
Indy really hits a timing when they're
down two lanes of racks do you think
that that's a possibility this game as
there
yes two racks are down the anime music
comes up oh he goes like super mode the
game becomes a lot more hard to play and
against every odd prevail where's the
punch hill temper chained himself away
to safety PBT bobble someone worthy of
respect admiration and celebration
someone worthy of being called sama
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages